[MUSIC]
[BLANK_AUDIO]
[APPLAUSE].
>> Graduates, Phil Knight, honored guests,
faculty, staff,
families, and friends, welcome to the 2014
graduation
ceremony at Stanford University's Graduate
School of Business.
>> [APPLAUSE].
>> What does your graduation signify?
As you know, studying at the GSB means so
much more than mastering the concepts of
management.
It is as much about personal
transformation.
As you sit before us, eager to receive
your diplomas, I encourage you
to think about how you have changed and
grown during your time here.
Your graduation today celebrates all that
you have done and become.
And your readiness to have a dramatic and
positive impact on the organizations you
will lead, manage,
and found, and through those
organizations, the communities they serve.
What you have accomplished in your time at
the GSB you have not accomplished alone.
You have learned and received help and
guidance, mentorship and
support from many quarters.
All of which are represented here today.
First, you are sitting shoulder to
shoulder with your classmates.
As you have throughout your time here.
Think how much you have learned from one
another in squads,
clubs, study trips, talk, touchy feely, or
just in quiet conversation together.
You have forged bonds that will become
lifelong friendships which
will nurture and sustain you in the years
ahead.
Take a moment to show your appreciation
for
one another [APPLAUSE] Sitting behind me
on the stage is a group of faculty who
represent
the more than 200 tenure line faculty.
And practitioners who have been your
teachers, coachers, mentors,
study trip companions, career advisers,
and so much more.
I would ask the faculty to stand so that
your students can show their appreciation.
>> [APPLAUSE].
>> And at various locations throughout the
amphitheater are staff from the MBA,
MSX, and PhD programs.
Without their tireless efforts on your
behalf,
none of us would be celebrating here
today.
I ask the staff to stand, wherever they
are, and be recognized.
>> [APPLAUSE].
>> [APPLAUSE]
I have left the most important for last.
Each of you has been supported by family
and
friends as you will throughout your lives.
They've provided encouragement,
validation, love, and
yes, in many cases, financial support,
too.
While we will hand your diplomas to you,
you know that in
parentheses after your name, belong the
names of those who have nurtured you, and
supported you along the way.
This is your opportunity to stand and say
thank you to your friends and
family, who are celebrating your mutual
accomplishment with you.
[APPLAUSE] Most days during your
time in the new Knight Management Center,
you have walked through the town
square on your way to or
from class and have walked by,
around or through the replica
of an athletics track which holds
an inscribed quote from Phil Knight.
The quote begins, there comes a time in
every life.
Where the past recedes and the future
opens.
It's that moment when you turn to face the
unknown.
Stepping out of that athletics track into
the GSB, are a pair of sneaker prints.
>> From a pair of filth Nike's, and let's
all admit it,
in the privacy of this intimate gathering,
most of us have at one time or
another, put our own feet into those
footprints.
And stepped into the GSB.
I thank you for the myriad ways in which
you have stepped into the GSB,
and enriched it with your presence during
your time here.
Now you face one of those moments that
Phil talks about in the inscription,
where the future opens, and you turn to
face the unknown.
And at the end of the stage here today,
we have put down another pair of
footprints to encourage you all to
think about how you will step from the GSB
into the future.
I have three hopes for you as you take
that step.
First, take a huge stride.
At the GSB, we have not just encouraged
you to dream but
try to instill in you the courage to
pursue those dreams.
We have surrounded you by classmates who
can help you to nurture them.
And we have provided you with an education
that gives you the knowledge and
insight to guide you in your quest.
We have done this because we think that
the biggest problems in the world,
whether in education, global poverty,
health care,
the environment, water, governance or
business are at their core, business
leadership and management challenges.
There are big and important challenges,
and the world needs change agents,
who are willing to tackle them with
passion, and with innovative ideas.
Changing lives, organizations, and the
world requires that you dream big.
Second, walk with confidence.
It takes courage to lead and to innovate
in order to bring about real change.
Don't shy away from living a life of
impact and
meaning, even if that isn't always their
easiest road to walk.
Changing lives, organizations, and
the world requires not just ambition, but
purpose as well.
Third, walk together.
There's an old African saying which goes,
walk together, walk far.
Stay as tightly connected as you are
today,
and continue to support one another in
your aspirations.
And come back regularly and stay connected
to all of us.
Changing lives, organizations, and the
world is a team sport.
So as you walk off this stage today
diploma in hand and
you step into the future, take a big
stride.
Walk with confidence, and walk together.
We are looking forward to following your
journeys as you step out of the GSB today.
Our graduation speaker today is an alumnus
who has not just taken big strides
himself, but who, who has also created the
footwear with which to do it.
>> [LAUGH].
>> Phil Knight graduated from the Stanford
GSB with an MBA in 1962,
and went on to co-found Nike with Bill
Bowerman,
his former running coach, at his undergrad
alma mater, the University of Oregon.
You may think Phil turned to making shoes
instead,
because he wasn't any good at running in
them.
Not so.
Phil clocked a personal best of four
minutes, ten seconds in the mile.
Phil is a great guy.
And I don't just mean that in the narrow,
but
very impressive sense of someone who co,
co-founded and lead one of
the most successful influential and iconic
brands in the world.
Phil leads with character.
He's a man of integrity who has the
courage to speak his mind.
And he speaks from the heart.
I love that about him.
Phil is also a thoughtful and generous
philanthropist.
In addition to providing the lead gift of
$105 million to
enable the building of the Knight
Management Center and
being a great supporter of athletics at
the University of Oregon, Phil and
his wife Penny, last year pledged $500
million in matching funds.
That's $500 million.
[APPLAUSE] Towards the Knight Cancer
Institute at Oregon Health and
Science University, all of us, especially
those who either personally or
in our families have been touched by that
terrible disease,
thank Phil and Penny for their generosity
of spirit and resources.
Please join me in giving Phil Knight a
warm GSB welcome.
>> [APPLAUSE].
>> Thank you.
Thank you.
Dean Saloner, graduates, family,
friends, faculty, Dean Joss and
our honorable Condoleezza Rice,
I'm sorry that RJ Miller could not be here
today.
He would be the one person in this
gathering that would refer to
me as that young man.
>> [LAUGH].
>> I graduated from this school in 1962,
more than half a century ago.
It was a time when jet travel was
just beginning with the introduction of
the Boeing 707.
There was no Silicon Valley, per se.
There were no ISPACS machines, there was
no internet,
there were no cell phones, no iPads.
The latest technology, technological
development was the colored tv.
There was no such thing as venture
capital.
The number one company in the world was
General Motors.
The biggest firm on Wall Street was
Merrill Lynch, Pierce, Fenner & Smith.
Commercial banks were not allowed to
engage in investment banking activities.
And there was no birth control pill.
>> [LAUGH].
>> There was absolutely nothing in my
journey that has
any specific application for what awaits
you.
In so many ways, today's talk could be
called Return of the Dinosaur.
Why, therefore, why, before this, the
greatest
class ever to graduate from this best
business school on the planet.
>> [APPLAUSE].
>> Why, why did the dean ask me to be
here?
And my answer is I don't really know.
>> [LAUGH]
>> But I suppose there may be
some hope that parts of my journey might
be relevant in attitude and philosophy.
I hope so.
But why I, a person who intensely dislikes
public speaking chose to accept,
is perfectly clear to me.
The answer is, it is personal.
For me, it's a rounding of the circle.
There's a part of me that was born here.
I had come here, at age 22, a bit lost.
For me, an extrovert was a person who
stared at other people's shoes.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Shy, insecure, unsure of what I wanted
to do with my life.
Two years later, I left.
Much better educated.
I was still shy and insecure, but I knew
what I wanted to do.
If only, I could pull it off.
And that was to bring to life the business
plan written in
Frank Shellenberger's Entrepreneurship
Class.
So I returned, 52 years after my own
graduation, to this place,
this magical place which is an extended
part of me.
I return to say thank you here where all
the aspiration began.
In the summer between my first and second
year,
I'd had a long existential debate with
myself, finally concluding that I would,
before going to work for 40 years, take
one year to go around the world,
looking for education, for enlightenment,
looking for myself.
And then the winter term of my second
year,
I took that entrepreneurship class, whose
road led to Japan.
So after putting in my required two weeks
of U.S. Army summer camp at Fort Ord,
selling my car, saying bon voyage to
parents and sisters,
I set out with Gary Carter who I met when
we were both living in Crothers Hall.
In September we were ready to go.
We drove down El Camino to the liquor
store that was the ticket agent for
Standard Airways, a discount charter
airline.
For $80, we got on a Convair 880,
a prop of course, leaving from Moffat
Field, eight hours to Hawaii.
We would surf in the mornings and
sell encyclopedias door to door in the
early evening.
I'm sure I'm the only graduate in the
history of this school,
whose first job after graduation was
selling encyclopedias.
>> [LAUGH]
>> After a month of this,
I was ready to go on, but Gary had met a
girl he liked a little too much to leave.
So now I'm stuck with a decision, go home,
or not go at all.
I loved Japan instantly.
The people were friendly, and many parts
of the countryside scenic.
And the Yen was 3.60 to the dollar.
So, so many things were affordable, like
hotel rooms, and meals, and
athletic shoes.
After a week I'd run my way to Kobe which
was the headquarters of
Onitsuka Company Limited, manufacturer of
Tiger athletic shoes,
which I identified as the best quality,
the ones with the best chance of getting a
piece of the US market.
I called on the telephone and explained I
was a US businessman in town.
And I had an interest in distributing
their shoes in the United States.
I got an appointment.
I donned my one business suit, Brooks
Brothers,
with a blue Oxford shirt, black neck tie,
I slipped on my black Bailey loafers, and
took a taxi to the wrong location.
>> [LAUGH].
>> I couldn't read the signs.
[LAUGH]
I'd gone to the show room, they
wanted me at the manufacturing facility,
completely on the other side of town.
So, I show up a half hour late, I'm
already nervous.
And even though it was a cool day, I was
sweating heavily.
I'm met at the door by a 30ish man.
Ken Miyazaki, who reached me warmly and
users me through to a conference room in
the back of the building.
On the way to the room we pass through the
accounting department which has
about 20 employees, they all stand up and
bow.
The big business man from the US, [LAUGH]
don't you know?
My entire assets are on my body.
>> [LAUGH]
[APPLAUSE]
>> That business suit, and my around the
world airline ticket.
It occurred to me that I might not get out
of there alive.
>> [LAUGH]
>> There are a half a dozen Japanese
businessmen waiting in the conference
room.
How does a shy, insecure person make a
sales presentation?
Sell as if your life depended on it.
Which it sorta did, didn't it.
[COUGH] But I must confess, when I
said I sold encyclopedias door-to-door in
Honolulu, it was a little imprecise.
I called on houses door-to-door trying to
sell encyclopedias,
I never actually closed a sale.
>> [LAUGH].
>> After a very awkward beginning,
we got into the specifics about what was
needed for the US market.
The talks warm up and eventually become
enthusiastic.
They have been thinking about getting into
the US market and have several track and
field sample models built on patterns of
the US foot.
They have an all-purpose model they call
the Limber Up.
To have a high jump model called the
spring-up,
and a shot discus shoe they call the
throw-up.
[COUGH].
>> [LAUGH].
>> I might be able to help them.
>> So we end with me placing an order of
15 pair of samples.
And after I leave, I sit alone on a chair
in the chaotic Osaka airport and
ask myself again, where am I going?
I am very excited about the meeting with
[UNKNOWN] and one part says,
this is exactly what I want.
I should race home and get this business
going.
The other said, if you don't go around the
world now, you'll not go for
four or five decades.
I flew to Hong Kong.
Which is a good thing.
The samples didn't arrive for 14 months.
When the samples finally came in, I showed
them to my old coach Bill Bowerman,
who was so impressed he asked to let him
in on the deal.
We shook hands on a 50 50 partnership, and
each of us put 500 dollars.
We bought 300 pairs of shoes.
First year sales were $8,000.
We made a $250 profit.
In 1964 my life got busy.
By day I was a CPA for Price Waterhouse.
My Army reserve requirement takes up two
days, two Tuesday nights a month and
one all-day Sunday plus two weeks in the
summer.
Dating with mixed success, and
all the while my real love is that little
company that Bauman and I have started.
We get to $100,000 in sales, we get to
$500,000, then a million.
I multitask, I can drive a car, eat a
McDonald's fillet of fish sticks and
read a newspaper all at the same time.
>> [LAUGH].
>> I was pretty efficient for
a couple years, until I rear-ended the car
in front of me.
>> [LAUGH].
>> It took a lot of time to get insurance
companies lined up, and
my own car repaired, and the cuts on my
forehead fixed.
So, I don't do that anymore.
By 1972, we got to $2 million in sales,
with a 3% net profit, but
it hadn't been easy.
After all, $500 apiece doesn't provide
much equity, even for $2 million.
I had tossed in most of my Price
Waterhouse checks for
four years, but I was spending four days a
week at the bank trying to
convince them to give us a little more
credit.
By now, I have quit Price Waterhouse, and
I'm going full time, and
somewhere in the process my search for
credit put me in touch with [INAUDIBLE].
The sixth largest Japanese trading
company,
with annual sales of 100 billion dollars.
We began developing a positive
relationship.
Meanwhile, [UNKNOWN] had brought a 32 year
old hotshot,
[UNKNOWN] with a charge to expand export
sales.
Export sales were primarily us.
So, young Mr. [UNKNOWN] brings me the
following offer.
Sell us 51% of your company at book value,
or we'll set up other distributors,
regardless of what that piece of paper
that we signed says.
With com, Katani's ultimatum, I did an
instant cost benefit analysis,
which led me to this dilemma, how do you
say go to hell in Japanese?
>> [LAUGH].
>> So there I am, 34 years old, married, a
three-year-old son, 80% mortgage
on my house, 45 employees, a personal
guarantee of $750,000 company loan,
inventory going more obsolete by the day,
and no new product to sell.
We had a team that had taken, that had
been nothing eight years before, and
built it up to become recognized in the
sporting goods world.
And that team had designed the three
top-selling Tiger running shoes.
We had a large pot of coffee and
the support of the sixth largest Japanese
trading company.
And that trading company could and
did introduce us to every shoe factory in
Japan.
And provided the financing to import those
products.
But then there was the little matter of
the lawsuits, plural.
One in the US, one in Japan.
I get my cousin, Doug Houser,
Stanford Law, 1960 to take our case on a
contingent fee.
It took three years, we won both suits.
Meanwhile, we paid $35 to a graphic arts
student at Portland State College to
give a rendition of the side logo on the
shoe, the logo now called the swoosh.
Years later, she was interviewed by the
Portland Oregonian and
asked her what her second biggest project
was.
She answered, Walla, wallpaper for a Walla
Walla motel.
>> [LAUGH].
>> We had each of the 45 employees submit
a suggestion for a brand name.
Jeff Johnson, 1963 Stanford graduate, who
I had met on a workout at Angel Field and
who was our first employee, submitted the
name Nike.
Well I said, I don't really like it that
much, but
it's better than any of the other 44 and
hoped, hopefully it would grow on us.
We were no longer limited to track and
field shoes.
So we brought in wrestling shoes, tennis
shoes, basketball shoes as well.
Sales grew to 3.2 million dollars.
But our first, we had our first ever loss.
Plus one other little problem.
We got kicked out of our bank.
Too much leverage, not enough cash.
The state of Oregon only had two big
banks, and
we'd been thrown out of the other one two
years before.
[UNKNOWN]
stood in for the bank until we found one,
The First State Bank of Milwaukee-Oregon.
A small bank, but we made it work.
So there I was,
sitting at my desk, more relaxed than any
time in more than a decade.
In the period between getting cut off by
Tiger and
establishing a banking relationship with
the First State Bank of Milwaukie, Oregon.
Sales merely through the introduction of a
running shoe with a waffle sole,
had risen to $25 million with solid
profitability, profitability.
Oh yes.
Right at the top of the morning mail,
letterhead says, United States Customs.
An announcement that this is an important
letter.
It turned out to be so.
Attached was an invoice for past through
custom duties of 25 million dollars.
The exact same number as our total sales
for the year.
I had no idea what they were talking
about.
And so what we find out,
there's a little use part of the customs
code dating back to the 1930s.
Duty in three categories, benzedrine
chemicals, cherry stone clams and
athletic footwear with synthetic uppers,
could be assessed.
Not the factory cost of the goods but,
on the American wholesale selling price of
those goods in in fact good were like or
similar, if you like that language, to
American manufactured goods.
So here comes this invoice, and in spite
of the fact that we'd been charged and
paid the amounts that we had been
invoiced, for, we'd been invoiced for
previously, our prices have been based on
that and long ago been sold.
The $25 million was on top of that.
But things were fuzzy and inclear, fuzzy
and unclear.
One thing was absolutely certain.
No way were we going to be able to pay
that amount of money, so
I go to Washington, DC, reaching as high
up in the political ladder as I can.
When first contemplating imported nylon
upper running shoes,
we had asked Customs for a ruling on what
the duty would be.
When shown the letter signed by the
Assistant Director of
Customs stating our duty would be 20% of
our factory cost, not the double that.
That we were being assessed, the response
of John P.
Simpson, Deputy Assistant Secretary.
Well that letter is not binding on US
customs.
In other words, we lied to you.
You screwed up.
You trusted us.
And gradually we began to figure it out.
This obscure rule had been on the books
for nearly half a century.
And now US shoe manufacturers, Converse
and others, banded together to
lobby the government to ply the extra duty
on athletic shoe imports and
general and us in particular.
They had to make something that met the
test of a customs officer who likely had
never worked in a shoe factory, as in like
or similar.
And they then had to sell only a few of
those shoes to hugely increase the cost of
our shoes going forward if,
in fact, the retroactive part didn't put
us out of business, which it nearly did.
Thus began the great ASP fight, a fight
for our very lives.
It lasted three years.
I am in a secret business and I've got to
have a Washington D.C. lobby.
Most lobbying firms on K street were more
than willing to take our case for
a fee of $1,000 an hour.
We hired Jay Edwards, Stanford '68, he had
just opened an office representing
Portland General Electric, the Oregon
public utility and the Nez Perce indians.
And now for a retainer of $300 a month.
Us, any over, around and through, we
fought like bastards.
Our cause was just, the government was
aligned with the forces of evil, and
if we lost, if we lost, we were kaput.
But I believe that fight made a huge
imprint on our culture,
which lasts to this day.
We joined the American footwear
manufacturers and then sued them.
>> [LAUGH].
>> We made an inflammatory TV commercial,
which ended with the tag line, if this
little shoe company goes out of business,
a little bit of Yankee freedom dies with
us.
>> [LAUGH]
>> No reputable TV network or channel
would show it.
[COUGH]
>> [LAUGH].
>> We got on the air on a New England
religious channel between 12 and
one in the morning.
>> [LAUGH].
>> It generated three letters, all of them
positive.
That having failed,
we took a portable tv set, showing the ad
during the presidential campaign of 1976,
showing it in cafeterias, diners, and
pizza parlors all over New Hampshire.
And that managed to get the attention of
the political establishment,
at least a little bit.
And there was lots of shoe leather in
D.C., including plenty of my own.
We had support from the Oregon delegation,
plus Al Gore and
Jim Sasser of Tennessee, where we had our
central warehouse.
In one of our meetings at treasury,
the official said, you can tell your
Senator Hatfield to quit calling.
It's not doing you any good.
I left his office and
called Mark Hidfeld's office and said,
keep up the good work.
[COUGH]
>> [LAUGH]
>> Our one in house lawyer, Rich Warskill,
Stanford '68.
Lived for two years in Washington, DC.
He and Jay Edwards simply outworked,
out-thought, out-emotioned the opposition,
and did a better job in this case than any
of those K Street lawyers would have.
In perhaps our best maneuver, we came up
with this one.
We had a factory in Exeter, New Hampshire,
making 15,000 pair a month.
What if we created a second line, knocked
off
ourselves selling the discounters a very
low but marginally profitable price.
No one could copy us closer than we could
copy ourselves.
When the first came up in a brainstorming
session everybody laughed at its
absurdity, then we looked at each other.
The whole law was absurd.
And it evolved into eventually let's try
it.
Thus was born the one line, which over a
couple of years,
sold a couple thousand pairs and reduced
the increase in our duties by two thirds.
And after three years of fighting, we
settled the great ASP customs battle.
For $9 million, approximately one third of
the former demand.
And in those three years our sales had
grown to $140 million and
we could actually pay the bill.
One year after the settlement we got ASP
eliminated from all,
from the entire US customs clode, code,
from benzedine chemicals and
cherrystone clamps, as well as footwear
with synthetic uppers.
While it would reach the critical mass to
go public all during the ASP years we
could not go public because we could not
accurately report earnings
which were very materially affected by the
ultimate ASP resolution.
With the resolution of ASP a public
offering was open to us,
and in December 1980.
We did just that.
And from that point, the only thing
standing in the way of real success,
of having our dreams come true, was
ourselves.
I don't really like lessons learned type
lectures.
But there have been a few along the way.
And on this special occasion, I can't help
myself.
Indulge me, I'll not be doing this again.
>> [LAUGH]
>> The goal should not be to seek a job or
even a career but to seek a calling.
That search has just begun.
Now that you have grad,
now that you have graduated the goal
should not be to seek a job.
Or even a career but, you should be, seek
a calling.
In your time here, you've probably gone
through 50 or 100 different case studies.
And in the years ahead, you'll probably go
through thousands more.
Those case studies are not about decision
making,
not even about judgement, they are about a
search for wisdom.
I have in my travels, occasionally, met
promising young people who
insist they're not going to ask for help
along the way.
They want to figure it out themselves.
Mine was the opposite approach.
It is hard enough out there.
Get all the help you can.
Getting help really is just a part of a
life long search for wisdom.
Here are just a few of the people who
stooped to help us along the way, and
all but one of the following began their
help before we were ever a public company.
Chuck Robinson, Deputy Secretary of State
to Henry Kissinger.
Jill Conway, President of Smith College,
Dick Donahue,
at 28-years-old, a congressional liaison
for John Kennedy.
Ralph Denuncio, president of the New York
Stock Exchange, Tom Paine,
the Executive Director of NASA.
Masaru Hayami, the president of Nissho
Iwai.
As we increased our volume,
we became Nissho Iwai's most profitable
customer in the world.
Which got me into meetings with their CVO,
CEO.
We developed a friendship, and for five
years in a row,
I spent I weekend with him and his wife at
their beach cabin near Atami.
Which wasn't just a pleasant weekend it
was also a tutorial
on business and leadership.
Two years after he stepped down from
Nisho, Masaru Huyami was named
the governor of the Bank of Japan which is
the Federal Reserve of Japan.
When he passed away, at his memorial
service in Tokyo.
Per his instructions, draped over his
coffin was a Nike banner.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
And don't be afraid to come back to the
school that spawned you.
Frank Schalanburger always raised my
spirits when,
when I was feeling low and wanted to get
ahold of him.
Bob Davis and Mike Spence each spent ten
years on the Nike Board of Directors.
And there are a couple other lessons.
Two nines working together will beat two
tens working for
their own careers, every time.
Ability and desire most always trump money
and power.
If you can't get financing, don't be
afraid to go 7,000 miles from home.
Government is part of business, any
business.
There is such a thing as managing
creativity, and dare to take chances,
lest you leave your talent buried in the
ground.
And where there is no struggle.
There can be no art.
And finally, there's this thought, ten
years from now
the first of you will be asked to give the
commencement speech to what will then be
the finest class in the school's history.
You'll be a bit torn.
You will multitask to the max.
Two kids.
One has an ear infection and needs to get
to the doctor right away.
Your husband is more needy than usual and
he has a flight in the morning to Europe
for ten days.
Your company is at a critical point in
its' strategic planning and
everybody looks to you for what the
answers will be.
Plus the company has a PR crisis, and
you have TV appearances scheduled for five
days straight.
And that Golden Lab you had for
two years, has all of a sudden decided
it's not housebroken.
There is not time, there is no time, and
then you'll accept.
Because of the honor.
Because it's a chance to have some
influence on the most able,
best prepared young people on the planet.
And you will accept though it is hard to
see now, because there's a part of you
that longs to go back to a place and a
time and a self forever gone.
In looking for things to say,
include in your consideration moments from
the school's history.
You might even look back to that time from
the deep past,
that moment from over six decades before
when Frank Shellenberger,
beloved professor of entrepreneurship,
said the words that meant so much to me.
The words that became the mantra for his
class, the words that
said the only time you must not fail is
the last time you try.
>> [APPLAUSE].
>> Thank you Phil for those inspiring and
dare I say, most memorable words.
We thank you for all that you've done for
the school over the years.
It is now my great honor and
pleasure to introduce you to the GSB PhD
class of 2014.
>> [APPLAUSE].
>> Our PhD program is small and exclusive.
With an admission rate well under 10%.
These individuals that are about to come
before you come here as students,
dedicating themselves to two or three
years of course work in an intensive
apprenticeship in conducting research in
their chosen fields.
Having become true experts.
They leave us as colleagues, setting out
on a path to create new knowledge.
Today we formally celebrate their
transition from students to
future intellectual leaders who will play
an important role in shaping our
understanding of business and management.
After their advisors placed the hood of
the Stanford Business School on them.
They will join us on stage, as we welcome
them into our profession, as colleagues.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Omar [UNKNOWN].
>> [APPLAUSE]
[BLANK_AUDIO]
[APPLAUSE]
>> Lin William Sung.
>> [APPLAUSE].
[BLANK_AUDIO]
[APPLAUSE].
>> Sunna Sierra Indra Data.
>> [APPLAUSE]
[BLANK_AUDIO]
[APPLAUSE].
Joel Gogh.
>> [APPLAUSE]
[BLANK_AUDIO]
[APPLAUSE].
>> Brianna Cardiff
Hicks.
>> [APPLAUSE].
[BLANK_AUDIO]
[APPLAUSE].
>> Dimitri Orlov.
>> [APPLAUSE]
[BLANK_AUDIO]
[APPLAUSE].
>> Talley Rike.
>> [APPLAUSE]
[BLANK_AUDIO]
[APPLAUSE].
>> Simet Watawasari.
>> [APPLAUSE]
[BLANK_AUDIO]
[APPLAUSE].
>> The Master of Arts in Business
Research,
recognizes the accomplishments of students
who have completed the course work, and
fulfilled the research requirements of the
Masters degree.
And thus, have become domain experts.
But are not continuing on to do the
further work required for the PhD degree.
This year's candidate for Master of Arts
in Business Research is Aaron Lee.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> So this year marks the 42nd class of
students who
graduate with a certificate in public
management and social innovation.
Founded by Dean Emeritus RJ Miller, the
certificate program educates leaders
committed to social and environmental
change.
Today's graduates earning the certificate
really do embody the spirit of our motto,
Change lives, change organizations, change
the world.
These students have already shown their
commitment using management skills to
alleviate global social problems.
For example, they participated in a wide
range of social innovation courses
covering topics such as social enterprise,
health care innovation, the business of
education, business at the bottom of the
pyramid, and sustainable energy markets.
They explored roles with high social
impact such as board governance,
impact investing, and philanthropy.
They traveled on social innovation study
trips to places like, Argentina, Brazil,
Cambodia, Vietnam, India, Kenya, and Nepal
among others.
To see for themselves what is being done
to address extreme poverty,
urban migrations, sustainability, and
more.
Some of these students have developed
their own social enterprise and
are ready to launch right after
graduation.
I am proud to tell you that this year, we
have 99 recipients of the certificate in
Public Management and Social Innovation.
Their names are listed in the commencement
program.
I now ask those 99 students to stand.
>> [APPLAUSE].
>> And I would like us to recognize him
for
completing a formal course of study in the
Management of Public Nonproft and
Social Issue Organizations in addition to
earning our MBA and MSX degrees.
Congratulations.
>> [APPLAUSE].
>> Good afternoon on this festive day.
It is now my pleasure as director of the
Stanford MSX program, to present
this year's graduates who will receive the
degree of master of science in management.
The mission of the MSX program is to
provide experienced leaders, men and
women who have already spent at least
eight years in professional and
management roles.
The opportunity to prepare themselves for
increasingly senior positions in the
organizations they lead.
The program is a full-time year-long
course of academic study.
While studying at Stanford, these students
carry the title of Sloane Fellows.
This year's 83 fellows came to Stanford
from across the United States and
30 additional countries.
Most fellows have families that join them
for the year.
Many are sponsored by their employers.
Others are self-sponsored and
include those who will create innovative
new enterprises after graduation.
Having completed all the academic
requirements of the program,
this year's fellows will now join the
worldwide family of GSB alumni.
On behalf of the administration of the
program, and
the faculty who have taught them.
Join me in wishing each of them great
fulfillment and
success in the next phase of their
careers.
>> [APPLAUSE].
>> I will now read their names while Dean
Saloner and
Professor George Parker present the
diplomas.
Asra Maxwell
Azraham.
>> [APPLAUSE].
>> Kyung Min Bang.
>> Peter Sewell Blanc.
>> [APPLAUSE].
>> Chris Baggianno.
>> Jonathan Matthew Baggianno.
>> [APPLAUSE].
>> Nikola Boyd.
>> Flora Caranya Robayo Caramaschi.
>> [APPLAUSE]
[APPLAUSE].
Marcello Setobal Caramaski.
Greg Carico.
[APPLAUSE].
May Uchia Chen.
Rajat Chachubeddi.
[APPLAUSE].
Min Chin.
Guianbo Chang.
[APPLAUSE].
Bruce Choi.
Alexi Dang.
[APPLAUSE].
Narum Batar Dashdorg.
Pedro Drummond.
[APPLAUSE].
Hazim Alhagrasi.
Tatiana [UNKNOWN].
[APPLAUSE].
Alonso Franco.
Yianling Fu.
[APPLAUSE].
Edmundo Fuentes.
Santiago Garcia Martinez.
[APPLAUSE].
Antonio Garcia Sancegar.
Eve Fong Go.
[APPLAUSE].
John Joong Ha.
John Holdin.
[APPLAUSE].
Kwan Hui Hao.
Victor Huang.
[APPLAUSE].
Ricardo Ibarra Garcia Parra.
Anatoly Ignatucha.
[APPLAUSE].
Adnan Rasul Iqbal.
Doctor Mary Therese Jacobsen.
[APPLAUSE].
[UNKNOWN] Chotiros.
Fari Karam.
[APPLAUSE].
Sung Woo Kim.
Masato Kimura.
[APPLAUSE].
Audi Corinadi.
Siro Labiti.
[APPLAUSE].
Igor Larow.
Leming Lee.
[APPLAUSE].
Sonny Lieu.
Mary Macpherson.
[APPLAUSE].
David Masant.
Johnathan McKeeber.
[APPLAUSE].
Nioki Misoguchi.
Oswat Mohan.
[APPLAUSE].
Eric Moon.
Charles Jason Christopher Moran.
[APPLAUSE].
Michelle Lynn Morris.
Rob Nagel.
[APPLAUSE].
Ritu Narayan.
Anastasia Onegina.
[APPLAUSE].
Phillipe Ortiz Oregura.
Arturo Palma Matateach.
[APPLAUSE].
Theresa Lingnon Pan.
Amit Suneil Panda.
[APPLAUSE].
Sun Min Park.
Pedro Pubio.
[APPLAUSE].
Salo Ro, Roberto.
Paula Rosen.
[APPLAUSE].
Anker Sharma.
Anu Sharma.
[APPLAUSE].
Svetlana Smikova.
Douglas Silva.
[APPLAUSE].
Siddhartha Shakar.
Avinash Sud.
[APPLAUSE].
Randy Sternkey.
Ram Subermanian.
[APPLAUSE].
Than Kok Yam.
Doctor Num Tantu Wanet.
[APPLAUSE].
Bruno Taeshaera.
Wing Han Edward Toh.
[APPLAUSE].
Jin Tomioka.
Jerod Tuck.
[APPLAUSE].
Aulani Wilhelm.
Eric Wittrick.
[APPLAUSE].
Vanessa Xi.
Kunal Yadav.
[APPLAUSE].
Kechow Yang.
Chi Long Yu.
[APPLAUSE].
Distinguished guests, faculty, staff,
family, and friends.
The MBA students gathered before us today
achieve great distinction.
[APPLAUSE] Two years ago,
they successfully navigated our extremely
competitive admissions process, right.
[APPLAUSE].
>> [LAUGH].
>> Since then, there were quiet, solid
foundations in general management.
>> [LAUGH]
[APPLAUSE]
>> I love them.
And have pursued deeper study in their
areas of interest.
>> [LAUGH].
>> They have engaged in personal growth
and
built relationships that will last a
lifetime.
They have helped the school and the
community in many extremely valuable ways.
They are an impressive group and are ready
and
worthy to join the ranks of our
illustrious alumni.
Therefore ladies and gentlemen, it is my
great honor and
privilege to present to you the Stanford
MBA Class of 2014.
[APPLAUSE].
You are the 89th MBA graduating class at
the Stanford GSB.
And to echo what Phil Knight said,
in my somewhat biased opinion, the best
class yet.
>> [NOISE] [APPLAUSE].
>> So as you leave to lead lives of impact
and meaning, I fully expect that your
accomplishments at Stanford will pale in
comparison to your future achievements.
But I hope your memories of the GSP will
remain fresh and
that you'll continue to be involved with
the school.
Our alumni played an important role in
your academic experience ranging from
being judges during executive challenge to
coming back to be your lectures in
entrepreneurial courses.
It is my wish that you too will engage
with the GSP as alumni.
And give your time and experience
generously to future classes.
Your classes already demonstrated its
desires to stay connected to the GSB and
to support the school in a meaningful way
through your participation in
the class gift program.
I must recognize the extraordinary result
of over 94% of you pledging to
give back to the GSB.
[APPLAUSE].
We plan to make house calls to the other
6% very soon, okay?
So you will leave your own legacy and play
a part in bringing the GSP experience to
future generations, as other alumni have
done before you.
At this time, I'd like to ask the Arbuckle
Leadership Fellows to stand.
[APPLAUSE].
The Arbuckle Leadership Fellows Program,
keep,
keep standing, plays an integral role in
our leadership curriculum by
bringing together a group of talented
second-year students to
support the leadership development of the
MBA one class.
On behalf of the GSB, I thank these 68
students for
their tireless work, their extraordinary
dedication to their MBA one squads and
coaches, and for inspiring an
unprecedented number of
first-year students to seek out this
unique leadership opportunity.
They are a role model for student
leadership at its best.
Please join me in another round of
applause for
this remarkable group of students.
[APPLAUSE]
[APPLAUSE].
>> I'd now like to ask the student leaders
of the Global Study Trips,
the Social Innovation Study Trips, and
the Stanford-Tsinghua Exchange Program to
stand.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
[APPLAUSE] These 95, these 95 outstanding
student
leaders partnered with the school on a
critical component
of the GSB education, the Global
Experience Requirement.
They've served as peer educators for over
600 students, traveling through 21
countries, discovering how business fields
are relevant in a myriad industries and
institutions, and proving what our faculty
teach them,
which is the different countries are
different.
[LAUGH] Okay?
For their ambassadorship of the GSB, and
their indelible impact on the students
they led, we thank them,
please join me again, in a round of
applause for these students, okay?
[APPLAUSE].
>> Thank you.
I would also like
to now acknowledge one of the faculty
sitting here.
Any of you who took BS Financial
Accounting had Anne Beyer as
your instructor.
[APPLAUSE] 'Kay?
[APPLAUSE].
>> So as you now, Anne Beyer won the MBA
Distinguished Teaching Award last year.
At commencement tomorrow, she is receiving
the Walter Gores Award for Excellence in
teaching, which is the highest award for
teaching at Stanford University.
[APPLAUSE]
In the next few minutes we will begin
reading
the names of the graduates in alphabetical
order, and will invite them forward to
receive their diploma.
Names will be read by Derrick Bolton,
Assistant Dean for
the MBA Admissions, the person who brought
you here.
[LAUGH] And Margaret, and Margaret Hayes,
Assistant Dean of the MBA Program,
the person who's making sure you leave on
time.
[LAUGH] 'Kay?
Graduates will receive their diplomas from
Dean Garth Saloner.
So all of you here have undoubtedly heard
of Arjay Miller, whom Phil alluded to, and
Glen as well.
It's my impression that many of the
graduating MBAs consider themselves
friends of Arjay Miller.
[LAUGH] 'Kay?
[APPLAUSE]
[LAUGH]
So Arjay served in the US Air Force during
the Second World War, and was later one
of the the so-called Whiz Kids who joined
Ford Motor Company and revolutionized it.
And Arjay rose to become President of Ford
and
then was the much admired fourth Dean of
the GSB from 1968 to 78.
His sterling leadership of the school is
legendary, and
in honor of Dean Arjay Miller's service,
the top 10% of the graduating class,
ranked by academic performance, are
designated, Arjay Miller Scholars.
So, as we read the names of the graduates,
we will announce if they have achieved the
distinction of Arjay Miller Scholar.
We will also acknowledge students in the
top 10% of the class,
who are in Joint Degree Programs, and so,
will be graduating in subsequent years.
So with that, Maggie and Derrick, could
you begin?
[APPLAUSE].
>> Caitlin Absher.
[APPLAUSE] Hannah Lucia Adania, Arjay
Miller Scholar.
[APPLAUSE].
>> Yeah.
>> Barber Wanda Afolabi.
[APPLAUSE]
Adil Agarwal
>> Yeah.
[APPLAUSE].
>> Basil Ahmad.
[APPLAUSE]
Khalid Al-Amri.
Amna Acasimi.
[APPLAUSE]
Akiduwa Aliday Komo.
Thad Alajuwan.
[APPLAUSE]
Bruno Alberti.
Manuel Aleman Presuela.
[APPLAUSE]
Natalia Alfonso.
Danielle Maria Allen.
[APPLAUSE]
Alvaro Javier Allende [UNKNOWN].
Aurelia Alvarado.
[APPLAUSE]
Padier Anomale.
Alexander Austin.
[APPLAUSE]
Daniele Otreak Ashavesta.
[APPLAUSE] Eduardo Fernandez Bieah Byer.
[APPLAUSE]
Zach Berez.
Matthew Bowman.
[APPLAUSE]
Catherine Becktall.
Adrian Baserono.
[APPLAUSE]
Luca Beltrami.
Christina Birgquist.
[APPLAUSE]
Basil Berry.
Jacob Best,
our general scholar.
[APPLAUSE] [UKNOWN] [APPLAUSE] Mikhail
[UNKNOWN] Bhat, Arjay Miller Scholar.
[APPLAUSE] Troy Michael Bienemann.
[APPLAUSE]
Kevin L Berninger.
[UNKNOWN]
[APPLAUSE]
Drew Botopauli.
Bradford Ludwig Bonney.
[APPLAUSE]
Carter Bowen.
Amanda Pearl Louise Bradford.
[APPLAUSE] Peter Dencar Brandt.
[APPLAUSE] William Stewart Broadbent Jr.
[APPLAUSE] Carlos Cabrera, Arjay Miller
scholar.
[APPLAUSE]
Segkin Challin.
[APPLAUSE] Paul William Campbell.
[APPLAUSE] Alexandra Carol.
[APPLAUSE]
Saul Michael Carlin.
[APPLAUSE] Stephanie Ann Carr.
[APPLAUSE]
Javier Castile.
Jonathan Casno.
[APPLAUSE]
Horas Jheri [UKNOWN] V.
Johnathan Avelaro.
[APPLAUSE] Laura Cervantes.
[APPLAUSE] Hersch Jonbria.
[APPLAUSE]
Cheryl Chan.
Neha Chauhan.
[APPLAUSE]
Fernando Chavira.
Monica Alexandra Chellum.
[APPLAUSE]
Daniel Chen.
Ivan Chen.
[APPLAUSE]
Paul Chen.
James [UNKNOWN].
[APPLAUSE]
[UNKNOWN]
Chen.
[APPLAUSE]
Ruchi Joudari.
Anna Louise Christie.
[APPLAUSE] Peirre-Jean Coubou.
[APPLAUSE]
Malcolm Collins.
Lauren Michelle Connelly.
[APPLAUSE]
Zoe Corneli, Arjay Miller Scholar.
[APPLAUSE] Candace Kelleher Corvetti,
Arjay Miller Scholar.
[APPLAUSE]
Felipe Cosmelli.
Patrick Coughlin.
[APPLAUSE]
Robert Sayer Craig.
[APPLAUSE] Carl Cummings, Arjay Miller
Scholar.
[APPLAUSE] Maya Dadu.
[APPLAUSE]
Veerla Dannon.
JC Danilovich.
[APPLAUSE]
Michelle Dawood.
[APPLAUSE] Guyatrice Rekanth Batar, Arjay
Miller Scholar.
[APPLAUSE]
Alexandra Ferrel Day.
[APPLAUSE] Doctor Lucas Antoine Devray.
[APPLAUSE]
Andre Charles Duhais.
[APPLAUSE] David DeCarlo, Arjay Miller
Scholar.
[APPLAUSE] William Barnett Daitch,
Arjay Miller Scholar.
[APPLAUSE]
Sal Dhanani.
Rodney B Dial the II.
[APPLAUSE]
Gabriel Victor Dobbs.
[APPLAUSE] Kristen Dobson.
[APPLAUSE] Natalie Dumond.
[APPLAUSE] Courtney Dang.
[APPLAUSE]
Johnny Dorsey.
Brendon Dowel.
[APPLAUSE] TJ Duane, Arjay Miller Scholar.
[APPLAUSE]
Brian Lee Robeles-Dunlap.
[APPLAUSE] Catherine Elkin.
[APPLAUSE]
Audrey Ellis.
[APPLAUSE] Paul Davis Emory, Arjay Miller
Scholar.
[APPLAUSE].
>> [APPLAUSE].
>> Emery Orton.
>> Nogan Assad Boroar.
[NOISE]
[APPLAUSE].
>> Gareth Davidson Evans, R.J. Miller
scholar.
>> [APPLAUSE].
>> Amanda Elizabeth Fesell.
>> Zujan Fan Andi.
>> [APPLAUSE].
>> Albert Farah Gabernet.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Alad Fervor.
>> [NOISE].
>> [APPLAUSE].
>> Yanis Fimber.
>> Alexandra Fisher.
>> [APPLAUSE].
>> Mary Catherine Flanagan.
>> [NOISE]
[APPLAUSE].
>> Hillary Fleischer.
>> [APPLAUSE].
>> Abigail Catelyn Flora.
>> Nick Francho.
>> [NOISE] [APPLAUSE].
>> Orley Diane Friedman.
>> [APPLAUSE].
>> Daniel Frisk.
>> Oren Benjamin Catsburg Gabriel.
>> [APPLAUSE].
>> Andrew Michael Gaines.
>> William Galvan.
>> [APPLAUSE].
>> Ambrose Glen Gayno.
>> [NOISE].
>> [APPLAUSE].
>> Luther Gatewood, R.J. Miller Scholar.
>> Ga Iong.
>> [APPLAUSE].
>> Kwali George.
>> [NOISE]
[APPLAUSE].
>> Projel Getoc.
>> [APPLAUSE].
>> Clint Gillam.
>> Monash Gogenami.
>> [APPLAUSE].
[NOISE].
Anthony E.
Gonzalez.
>> [NOISE] [APPLAUSE].
>> Mariana Gonzalez Araiza.
>> Maria Gonzalez Blanch.
>> [NOISE]
[APPLAUSE].
>> Matthew Gosselin.
>> [APPLAUSE].
>> Jacqueline Lee Grant.
>> Elliot Alpert Greenwald.
>> [NOISE].
>> [APPLAUSE].
>> Louis William Gresham.
>> [NOISE]
[APPLAUSE].
>> Steve Grossman.
RJ Miller Scholar.
>> [NOISE]
[APPLAUSE].
>> Eduardo Guemez Evalgo.
>> [APPLAUSE]
[NOISE] [APPLAUSE].
>> Ideti Gupta.
>> [NOISE] [APPLAUSE].
>> Ihnat Gupta.
>> [NOISE]
[APPLAUSE].
>> Suchin Gupta.
>> [NOISE] [APPLAUSE].
>> [UNKNOWN].
>> [APPLAUSE].
>> Brian Benjamin Gerwitz.
Raul Guiteridas Guran.
>> [APPLAUSE].
>> Navir Havad.
>> [NOISE].
[APPLAUSE].
>> Caleb Hafis.
>> [APPLAUSE].
>> Matthew Hale.
>> Hannah Hale Redfern.
>> [APPLAUSE].
[APPLAUSE]
>> Amanda Buell Hall.
>> [APPLAUSE].
>> Prudence Nicole Hallerman.
>> Rowad Halloway.
>> [APPLAUSE].
>> [NOISE] [APPLAUSE].
>> Thomas James Hand.
>> [APPLAUSE]
[NOISE].
>> Brenna Marie Hanley.
>> [NOISE]
[APPLAUSE].
>> Cynthia Humika Hardy.
>> [NOISE] [APPLAUSE]
[APPLAUSE].
Allison Heck, R.J. Miller Scholar.
>> [APPLAUSE].
>> Gillian Veronica Heltide.
>> Javier Hernandez.
>> [APPLAUSE].
>> Simone Hill.
>> Julian Henderling.
>> [APPLAUSE].
>> Michael Cramer Hoffman.
>> [NOISE] [APPLAUSE].
>> Michael Hall.
>> [NOISE]
[APPLAUSE].
>> Wakana Honda.
>> [NOISE].
[APPLAUSE].
>> Junji Hoshino.
>> [APPLAUSE].
>> Carolyn Stiles Hostetter.
>> Mitchell Scott Hauf.
>> [APPLAUSE].
>> Tim Hsia.
>> Scott Haga Hughes, R.J. Miller Scholar.
>> [NOISE]
[APPLAUSE].
>> Jun Ho-Wang.
>> [NOISE] [APPLAUSE].
>> Jared Hyatt.
>> Donna Every.
>> [NOISE]
[APPLAUSE].
>> Evan Henry Jacobs, R.J. Miller Scholar.
>> [NOISE]
[APPLAUSE].
>> Shelly Jacobson.
>> [NOISE]
[APPLAUSE].
>> Ernest Alexander Jacquet.
>> [NOISE]
[APPLAUSE].
>> Andrew Miller James, R.J. Miller
Scholar.
>> [NOISE].
>> [APPLAUSE].
>> Erica Janini.
>> Ryan Janson.
>> [APPLAUSE].
>> Ross Kyle Jenson.
>> [NOISE].
>> [APPLAUSE].
>> Benjamin Jensen.
>> Philip John.
>> [APPLAUSE].
>> Alfred I.
Johnson.
>> [APPLAUSE].
>> Barrett Alison Johnson, R.J. Miller
Scholar.
>> [APPLAUSE].
>> Courtney Ann Johnson.
>> Cori Jones.
>> [NOISE].
[APPLAUSE].
>> Jennifer Patricia Jordan.
>> [APPLAUSE].
>> Sarah Joyce.
>> Desel Calera.
>> [APPLAUSE].
Brain Thomas Kanard, R.J. Miller Scholar.
>> [NOISE] [APPLAUSE].
>> Kingsley Jr Cano.
>> [NOISE]
[APPLAUSE].
>> Arjun Kapoor.
>> [APPLAUSE].
>> Robert Katz.
>> Lauren Alexandra Keene.
>> [NOISE].
[APPLAUSE].
>> Christina Rigsby Kaiser.
>> [APPLAUSE].
>> Kristen Michelle Kelly, R.J. Miller
scholar.
>> [NOISE] [APPLAUSE].
>> Alex Kelston.
>> [APPLAUSE].
>> Charmaine Kinney.
>> Brendon Kariakis.
>> [APPLAUSE].
>> [NOISE] [APPLAUSE].
>> Chan Su Kim.
>> Sam Kents.
>> [NOISE]
[APPLAUSE].
>> John Ryan Kissic.
>> [NOISE]
[APPLAUSE].
Lauren Kolodny.
>> [APPLAUSE].
>> Kevin Coy.
>> Steve Coyers, R.J. Miller Scholar.
>> NOISE].
[APPLAUSE].
>> Marina Koshashinko.
>> [APPLAUSE].
Pete Kozyol.
>> [NOISE].
[APPLAUSE].
>> Adam Craneson.
>> [APPLAUSE].
>> [UNKNOWN]
R.J. Miller Scholar.
>> [APPLAUSE].
>> Silvia [UNKNOWN].
>> Christopher Kwok.
>> [APPLAUSE].
>> Ryan Gregory Lanford.
>> [NOISE]
[APPLAUSE].
>> Brian Leonard Latko.
>> Christine Adelaide Lee.
>> [APPLAUSE].
>> Shenha Lee.
>> Alex Lerner.
>> [APPLAUSE].
>> Jason Lane Leavey.
>> [NOISE].
[APPLAUSE].
>> Vincent Christopher Gaudiani Lay.
>> Rosa Lee.
>> [APPLAUSE].
>> Marina Leben.
>> [NOISE]
[APPLAUSE].
>> Allison Chang J Lynn.
>> [NOISE] [APPLAUSE].
>> Johnny Quo Han Lynn.
>> Shawn Lynn.
>> [NOISE] [APPLAUSE].
>> Susan Lin.
>> Scott Richard Littlefield.
[NOISE] [APPLAUSE].
>> [APPLAUSE].
>> Alberto Kenneth Lopez.
>> Brian Quinn Lovit.
>> [APPLAUSE].
>> Jessica Lu.
>> [NOISE].
[APPLAUSE].
>> Olivia Lineman.
>> [APPLAUSE].
>> Jamie Bergeron Lion.
>> Andreat Massado.
>> [NOISE].
[APPLAUSE].
>> Jau Maseto.
>> [APPLAUSE].
>> Troy Douglas Mably, Junior.
>> Aiden Madigan Curtis.
>> [NOISE]
[APPLAUSE].
>> Sabrina Celia Agan Manville.
>> [APPLAUSE].
Cheney Mow.
>> Gonzalo Margain.
>> [APPLAUSE].
>> Patrick Martinchek.
>> [NOISE] [APPLAUSE].
>> Kendra Mason.
>> Patricia Leigh Mason.
[APPLAUSE].
>> Arune M.
Matthew.
>> [NOISE] [APPLAUSE].
>> Adam Masur.
>> [APPLAUSE].
>> Julian McCarty.
>> [NOISE]
[APPLAUSE].
>> Awara Mende.
>> [APPLAUSE].
>> Brice William Meredig, RJ Miller
scholar.
>> [APPLAUSE].
>> Daniel Metrican.
>> Megan Danielle Meyer.
>> [APPLAUSE].
>> Judah Milunsky.
>> Matthew William Mo, top 10% of current
class.
>> [APPLAUSE].
>> Ferris Ali Mohudin, RJ Miller Scholar.
>> Michael Molinay.
>> [NOISE]
[APPLAUSE].
>> David Monteith.
>> [APPLAUSE].
>> Guy Mordecai.
>> Caleb Barenoff Morse.
>> [APPLAUSE].
>> [NOISE] [APPLAUSE].
>> Jeanine Nina Morton, RJ Miller scholar.
>> Jason [UNKNOWN].
>> [NOISE] [APPLAUSE].
>> Gregory Joseph Mulholland.
>> [NOISE]
[APPLAUSE].
>> Tamara Whitaker Mullings.
>> [NOISE]
[APPLAUSE].
>> Dianne Na.
>> [NOISE].
[APPLAUSE].
>> Hallad Nazith.
>> [APPLAUSE].
>> Dennis Negron.
>> Sasha Marie Nelson.
>> [NOISE].
[APPLAUSE].
>> Brent Newhouse.
>> [APPLAUSE].
>> Eric Newsonow.
>> Paloma Ochi.
>> [APPLAUSE].
>> [NOISE] [APPLAUSE].
>> Shannon Beth O'Donnell.
>> Devon O'Fallon.
>> [APPLAUSE].
>> Amanda Olson.
>> Joseph Onofrio.
>> [APPLAUSE].
>> Katka Oposinska.
>> Javier Orellama.
>> [NOISE]
[APPLAUSE].
>> Mariano Xavier Otero.
>> [APPLAUSE].
>> Maby Uguri.
>> Kyle Ozawa.
>> [NOISE] [APPLAUSE].
>> Frederica Bedesada.
>> [APPLAUSE].
>> Boein Pan.
>> Evo Parstivov.
>> [NOISE].
[APPLAUSE].
>> Ray Arcione.
>> [APPLAUSE].
>> Oscar Bennett Pate, R.J. Miller
Scholar.
>> [NOISE] [APPLAUSE].
>> Ahmit Patel.
>> Ryan Patrick Payne.
>> [APPLAUSE].
>> Sylvia Elas Martinez, R.J. Miller
Scholar.
>> [NOISE] [APPLAUSE].
>> Yale Aleg.
.
>> [NOISE].
[APPLAUSE].
>> Stephanie Ping.
>> [APPLAUSE].
>> Arun Pimetsa.
>> Elena Perez.
>> [NOISE] [APPLAUSE].
>> Terry Perez.
>> [NOISE]
[APPLAUSE].
>> Sean Phillips.
>> [APPLAUSE].
>> Alex Paresian.
>> Rachel Power.
>> [APPLAUSE].
>> Go, Rachel!
>> Julianna Prado Barbosa.
>> [APPLAUSE].
>> Sericha Prathi Bravi.
>> [NOISE]
[APPLAUSE].
>> Tyler Graham Price.
>> [APPLAUSE].
>> Cindy Prieto.
>> Maria Poron.
>> [NOISE]
[APPLAUSE].
>> Colin Patrick Quinn.
>> [APPLAUSE].
>> Katie Rafinelli.
>> Ted Rano.
>> [APPLAUSE].
>> Juan Pablo Ramos.
>> Sana Maria Rapako.
>> [APPLAUSE].
>> Jonas Rava, RJ Miller Scholar.
>> [NOISE] [APPLAUSE].
>> Robert Davis Radniss.
>> [APPLAUSE].
>> Niema Thasim Razna.
>> Luke Donald Redferg.
>> [NOISE] [APPLAUSE].
>> Jwoe Race.
>> [APPLAUSE].
>> Nefesa Rimtila.
>> John Richter.
>> [NOISE] [APPLAUSE].
>> Douglas James Rickett.
>> [APPLAUSE].
>> Nicholas Robin.
>> [NOISE]
[APPLAUSE].
>> Hailey Robison.
>> [APPLAUSE].
>> Pedro Rosha.
>> Brian J.
>> Rose, R.J. Miller Scholar.
>> [NOISE] [APPLAUSE].
>> David Rose.
>> Yeah, Dave.
>> [APPLAUSE].
>> David James Rosenthal.
[APPLAUSE].
>> Claudia Doege.
>> [NOISE] [APPLAUSE].
>> Go Claudia.
[APPLAUSE].
>> Daniel Sack.
>> [APPLAUSE].
>> Altaf Sayed.
>> Hiroshi Sakata.
>> [NOISE]
[APPLAUSE].
>> Omar Tariq Mohammad Ali Saleh.
>> [APPLAUSE].
>> Facile Samalies.
>> [NOISE]
[APPLAUSE].
>> Bo Santisotem.
>> [APPLAUSE].
>> Jacob Harrison Saper, top 10 percent of
the current class.
>> [NOISE] [APPLAUSE].
>> Naved Suriswith.
>> [APPLAUSE].
>> Tom Sayer, top 10 percent of the
current class.
>> [APPLAUSE].
>> David Shore, R.J. Miller Scholar.
>> [NOISE] [APPLAUSE].
>> Michael Daniel Schor.
>> [APPLAUSE].
>> Brett Sewell.
>> Mara Sagetti.
>> [NOISE]
[APPLAUSE].
>> Patricio Cervite.
>> [APPLAUSE].
>> Michael Gregory Sharf.
>> Kiana Sharifi.
>> [NOISE]
[APPLAUSE].
>> Johnathan Jasper Sherman Presser, R.J.
Scholar.
>> [NOISE] [APPLAUSE].
>> Michael Bruce Shore II.
>> [NOISE]
[APPLAUSE].
>> Zipo Sighakeney.
>> [APPLAUSE].
>> Maha Sing.
>> Lauren Elizabeth Smith.
>> [APPLAUSE].
>> Ryan Lee Smith.
>> Jason Saw.
>> [NOISE]
[APPLAUSE].
>> Adam Alexi Solomon.
>> [APPLAUSE].
>> Alexander Hartmann Soy.
>> Shana Lee Satko.
>> [NOISE] [APPLAUSE].
>> Gisha Spiller.
>> [APPLAUSE].
>> Derick John Stace-Naughton.
>> Benjamin Stanzel.
>> [NOISE]
[APPLAUSE].
>> Kirsten Leah Stazio.
>> [APPLAUSE].
>> Sebastian Steinhauser.
>> Louis Stern.
>> [NOISE] [APPLAUSE].
>> Allison Clark Stolaf.
>> [APPLAUSE].
>> Lucas Strozek, R.J. Miller Scholar.
>> [NOISE] [APPLAUSE].
>> Desiree Strozer.
>> [NOISE].
>> [APPLAUSE].
>> Paul Strosher.
>> Christine Sue.
>> [APPLAUSE].
>> Camila Talbot.
>> [APPLAUSE]
[APPLAUSE].
>> Joshua Tical.
>> [APPLAUSE].
>> Yuta Takinaski.
>> Ati Tanti Vurawang.
>> [APPLAUSE].
Alex James Tarzi, R.J. Miller Scholar.
>> Guy Tullis.
>> [APPLAUSE].
[APPLAUSE].
>> Kristen Bayer.
>> [APPLAUSE].
>> Lindsey Zenyetin.
>> Stefano Tissino.
>> [APPLAUSE].
[APPLAUSE].
>> Ryan Tong.
>> [APPLAUSE].
>> [UNKNOWN]
Johnson [UNKNOWN].
>> [APPLAUSE].
>> Nicholas Ryan Trutanik.
>> [SOUND] Lillian Sy [SOUND]
Eric Sitsilan [SOUND]
Sophie Turell.
>> [APPLAUSE].
>> Ting Ting Turskey.
>> Yeah Ting Ting.
>> [APPLAUSE].
>> Collin Steven Toomey, RJ Miller
scholar.
>> [APPLAUSE].
>> Aranimo Alberto Oribe Moreno.
>> Peter Dale Vareles.
>> [APPLAUSE].
>> Sebastian Von Renoir.
>> Roberto Vota.
>> [APPLAUSE].
>> Neha Vayez.
>> Colin Douglas Wallace.
>> [APPLAUSE].
>> Maggie Wallace.
>> Wai Ming Wong.
>> [APPLAUSE].
>> Yi Wong.
>> Kathleen Clark.
>> [APPLAUSE].
>> Melissa Sue-Ann Web.
>> Jesse Wedler.
>> [APPLAUSE].
>> Michael Scott Ort.
>> Rebecca Paige White.
>> [APPLAUSE].
>> Ingo Vegan.
Top 10% to the current class.
>> [NOISE].
[APPLAUSE].
>> Edward Wilkinson.
>> [APPLAUSE].
>> Grant David Wilson.
>> Vooba Wolf, RJ Miller Scholar.
>> [APPLAUSE].
[APPLAUSE].
>> Benjamin Wright.
>> [APPLAUSE].
>> Kelly Wright.
>> James [UNKNOWN].
>> [APPLAUSE].
[APPLAUSE].
>> Andrew Yafee.
>> [APPLAUSE].
>> Vincent Yang.
>> Mayan Yavna.
>> [APPLAUSE].
>> Siva Yelma Raju.
[APPLAUSE].
>> Neha Layla Yelarkar.
>> [APPLAUSE].
>> Anita Hong Hunyu.
[APPLAUSE].
>> Charles Young.
>> [APPLAUSE].
>> Rani Yi Yu.
>> Nicholas Sokrassik.
>> [APPLAUSE].
[APPLAUSE].
>> Samuel Boris Satz.
>> [APPLAUSE].
>> Fernando Zavala Guzman.
>> James [UNKNOWN].
>> [APPLAUSE].
[APPLAUSE].
>> Simon Shiamingza.
>> [APPLAUSE].
>> Masha Zoloto Chrylina.
>> Danielle Zonenshen.
>> [APPLAUSE].
>> Sally Zoe.
[NOISE].
>> [APPLAUSE].
>> [SOUND] Congrats, congratulations again
to the class of 2014.
It's now, it's now my pleasure to
introduce the presentation of awards.
Margaret Hazel will present the Arbuckle
award,
followed by Amadha Rajan who will present
the Robachek award and the Ford Scholar.
[BLANK_AUDIO].
>> The Ernest C.
Arbuckle Award is presented to a second
year MBA student who is nominated and
chosen by his or her peers.
The recipient, by his or
her active participation, initiative,
leadership and personal integrity.
As seen as having contributed most to the
fulfillment of the goals of
the Graduate School of Business, both
within school and society at large.
Classmates described this year's award
recipient as someone who went above and
beyond to ensure the GSB experience, in
both the academic and
extracurric, curricular realms, was
positive for everyone.
One of you wrote, this person, has, time
and
again, demonstrated a commitment to the
values and goals of the GSB.
In the classroom, this person is an active
participant.
Always prepared, and never hesitant to
chime in with a smart question or comment.
Some of you mentioned that this person has
helped you understand concepts, and
prepare for exams.
Outside of the classroom, this person has
shined, and
has probably coordinated more events than
anyone else in our class.
A number of classmates describe this
person as a kind and
committed friend, with a caring heart and
tremendous integrity.
One of you wrote, Hishi will always stop
to say hi.
Seems to have a nickname for everyone, and
doesn't go out of his or
her way to help a friend, classmate, staff
member,
faculty or anyone who happens to be
walking around campus.
You wrote that this person exemplifies the
GSB spirit by being one of
the most engaged and hardest working
members of your class.
This person served as an Arbuckle fellow,
leadership fellow, on the c for
c committee, and is co-president of GSB
gives back,
and co-chair of the charity auction and
white party.
In addition, hosted many informal social
gatherings for
the entire body, the student body.
>> [NOISE] [APPLAUSE].
>> I am delighted to present this year's
Arbuckle award to Peter Varellas.
Congratulations Peter.
>> [NOISE].
[APPLAUSE].
>> The Alexander Robichek Student
Achievement Award in Finance was
established to honor Professor Robichek's
outstanding contribution to the teaching
of finance at the Stanford School of
Business from 1960 till his death in 1978.
The award is given to an MBA student
selected by the finance faculty.
For outstanding achievement in finance
courses.
The recipient gets the award and also has
his or
her name engraved on the plaque at the
GSB.
I am delighted that this year's recipient
who has not only excelled in the study of
finance, but have also contributed to the
broader academic environment at the GSB.
By serving as a member of the academic
committee.
The 2014 Robocheck award winner is Dave
Shaw.
[NOISE].
[APPLAUSE].
>> [INAUDIBLE].
>> Among the Arjay Miller scholars,
one student's academic achievement places
him or her at the top of the class.
This student is designated as the Henry
Ford II Scholar and receives,
along with the Miller Scholar scroll, a
substantial cash award.
We are a business school, after all, they
say.
>> [LAUGH].
>> The recipient's name is also engraved
on a plaque on permanent display at
the GSB.
The 2014 Henry Ford Scholar is Brian Rose.
>> [NOISE]
[APPLAUSE].
>> Thank you.
>> [APPLAUSE].
>> Can we have one more rousing round
of applause for all of the graduates?
>> [NOISE]
[APPLAUSE].
>> That concludes the 2014 Standford
Graduate School of
Business Graduate Ceremony.
Thank you all for coming, and making this
a very special day.
I invite all of you to join us now for
receptions for each group of
graduates at the Knight Management Center,
as noted in your program.
Finally, please join me in a final round
of applause and thanks for
our guest speaker, [UNKNOWN].
[NOISE] [APPLAUSE].
[MUSIC].